well
the one really important thing is also
what they're doing well is
how to iterate that quickly which means
like it's not just about one time
deployment one building is constantly
iterating the network and trying to
automate as many steps as possible right
and that's actually the principles of
the
software 2.0 like you mentioned with
andre is
uh it's not just i mean i don't know
what the actual
his description of software 2.0 is if
it's just
high-level philosophical or there's
specifics but the interesting thing
about
what that actually looks in the real
world is
it's that uh what i think andre calls
the data engine
it's like it's the iterative improvement
of the thing
you have a neural network that uh does
stuff
fails on a bunch of things and learns
from it over and over and over so you're
constantly discovering edge cases
so it's very much about uh like data
engineering like
figuring out it's it's kind of what you
were talking about with testosterone is
you have the data landscape
you have to walk along that data
landscape in a way that uh
that's constantly improving the the the
neural network
and that that feels like that's the
central piece that yeah itself
and there's two pieces of it like
you you find edge cases that don't work
and then you define something that goes
get you data for that
but then the other constraint is whether
you have to label it or not like the
the amazing thing about like the gpt3
stuff is it's unsupervised
so there's essentially infinite amount
of data now there's obviously infinite
amount of data
available from cars of people
successfully driving
but you know the the current pipelines
are mostly running on labeled data which
is human limited
so when that becomes unsupervised
right it it'll create unlimited amount
of data which in the scale
now the networks that may use that data
might be way too big for cars
but then there'll be the transformation
from now we've unlimited data i know
exactly what i want
now can i turn that into something that
fits in the car
and that pro that process is going to
happen all over the place
every time you get to the place where
you have unlimited data and that's what
software 2.0 is about
unlimited data training networks to do
stuff
without humans writing code to do it
you